[Musique]
je suis à l'origine d'enseignante du
premier degré où j'ai principalement
exercé auprès des lèvres en grande
difficulté scolaire ou en situation de
handicap et puis ensuite je suis devenu
conseiller pédagogique inspectrice dans
le 1er degré je travaillais aussi en
administration centrale dans le bureau
qui s'occupait des enfants en situation
de handicap et puis par la suite je suis
devenu inspectrice pédagogique vie
scolaire et d'Aza adjoint dans les
Hauts-de-Seine et en scène Saint-Denis
et puis dernièrement mon dernier poste
était un poste de dazen en Loir-et-Cher
[Musique]
la convergence des trois territoires que
j'ai connus un territoire extrêmement
favorisé comme un peu comme ce que j'ai
pu connaître dans les Hauts-de-Seine un
territoire a été des endroits très
défavorisés comme ce que j'ai pu
connaître en Seine-Saint-Denis et puis
une partie rurale qui ressemble à ce que
j'ai pu connaître en Loir-et-Cher donc
c'est un territoire qui synthétise mes
expériences
[Musique]
ça serait présente monsieur de penser
qu'au bout d'un mois je peux déjà
imaginer des enjeux la mise en la mise
en musique de ce que nous demande le
ministre notamment autour des
concertations un travail sur la liaison
6e le travail au plus près des collèges
[Musique]
oui nécessairement nécessairement parce
que c'est un travail c'est un travail et
un engagement qui est un engagement
personnel c'est un sujet d'autant plus
important que vous le savez on est sur
une situation un peu compliquée si on
recrutement des ESH et que donc on va se
retourner vers les collectivités pour
unir nos forces pour essayer de recruter
au plus près des territoires les aesh
dans nos élèves ont besoin l'objectif
étant vraiment qu'on puisse couvrir 100%
des besoins puisque nous avons les
moyens et il nous manque juste les
ressources humaines
[Musique]